these are extraordinary times and we
face an extraordinary challenge
I thought Damien's instinct to shoot the
moon sequence on IMAX was really
inspired for those who had been to the
moon their senses were heightened they
felt to me like IMAX the sort of
clearest format that there is the most
epic format that there is would be a way
of making the audience share in that
feeling everybody should see the movie
in IMAX it's definitely an in theater
movie experience both in the visuals and
the sound if you see the movie in IMAX
you'll get that added experience of we
sort of referred to it when we were
making it a kind of our Wizard of Oz
moment where you step out of the lunar
module and once you step on to the lunar
surface the ratio expands it goes higher
from top to bottom
it's amazing how real it feels he's able
to work at a large scale but still keep
the environment feeling very intimate
and put people in the audience in the
pilot seat being sent to the moon
you
you